[Music]
I've been always on the other side of
the pageant world I don't have any
talent now leave you would never win
Miss America with that honey booboo nose
right fest best right now now it's mom
and Joon's turn in the spotlight her
300-pound weight loss the subject of her
Thuy TV reality series for not too hot
it's back for a second season and here's
what I learned
mama June is in it to win it I'm sorry I
can't walk in heels she thinks that she
is like this season professional if you
got a coach this is like the best coach
to get exactly what better coach for
June's pageant pursueth and
twelve-year-old daughter Ilana honey boo
boo was only six when she was killing it
on Toddlers and Tiaras do you think she
has what it takes probably probably not
thought coach mama juniors wrath wait
until you meet coach along I said she
need to work on anything was probably
Talent by telling cuz she doesn't even
have a crown in June's favor she's kept
most of her weight off after her gastric
sleeve surgery June went from 460 pounds
down to 160 and she says she's put on
about 10 pounds since you just need the
confidence that I have why is that
I think she's less confident right now
is because [ __ ] she's room smaller she's
gotten more hey cuz everyone's like oh
she's gonna gain the weight back
I've been very good it's been over a
year and a half and if you say gaining
10 pounds in a year and a half is bad
then it is what it is another good thing
for June a new mystery man in her life
this season she are you worried that
he's in it for the fame to be honest
with you hey didn't
know who I was we met I'm not sure if I
believe her I think he might be in it
for the headlines and also I did see a
preview of the first episode and guys
there's a lot of smooching in this
season
[Music]
you